good morning John I've heard a lot of
guesses about what it is that makes
humanity special opposable thumbs
tool use self-awareness but it turns out
all those things other animals do those
things do one thing I can never stop
thinking about though is music and of
course there are other organisms that
sing but here is a thing that no other
organism has ever done layers of remix
and collaboration and historical context
that go into that six second clip of a
barbershop quartet singing oops I did it
again are just well how are the tools
that we use to understand and manipulate
the world are built brick by brick by
individual humans and a lot of times we
can't see those bricks but with music
oftentimes we can several times in my
life have been listening to some old
interesting song that I'd never heard
before and then suddenly I realize I
have heard it before hundreds of times
you should probably tell that that's
about to happen with this song Ray
Charles obviously is iconic this song I
got a woman is one of the most covered
songs of all time and you probably know
that I got a woman was sampled fairly
recently in a super popular song but you
very well may have known that that was a
sample from Ray Charles and Kanye West's
gold digger but you probably did not
know about this
[Music]
the southern tones were a gospel group
raycharles hurt that song in the radio
and then immediately wrote I got a woman
using the same melody so that my friends
is the path from it must be Jesus to
call bigger this ridiculously beautiful
lobby surfer track is wonderful to
listen to it's called I got the it has a
lot of complexity a lot of orchestration
there's a lot going on and you probably
have never heard of it except Eminem if
you would like to email me I'm very
curious speaking of super weird this
Timmy Thomas track why can't we live
together is like a weird mix of organ
and percussion and it probably sounds
pretty familiar to you right now and you
may have figured out already but if you
haven't allow me to speed it up a little
bit add some reverb and take the high
end off and suddenly here's another song
that you almost certainly have never
heard before singing in the background
right now is Linda Linda she was a
backup act for Otis Redding and even
James Brown and when she released her
pretty spectacular R&B single what a man
it went bad because she was white the
KKK told her to retire otherwise they
would make her life miserable for being
a white person who was singing black
music and she did that and the song was
largely forgotten until
[Music]
in 2003 after salt-n-pepa's song came
out Linda Glendale actually came out and
performed her song what a man for the
very first time in public and now that
song leaves on again in another
hemisphere after Korean pop music group
I oh I did a version of it in 2016 some
people don't like samples they say that
it shows a lack of creativity or that
they're stealing from other artists so
when I look at this I see the example of
the thing that actually makes humans
unique and so powerful there are no new
things
I stole every one of these words I'm
saying from the person who made the word
up and we don't remember that person's
name so I find this beautiful and I love
to be able to see a little bit into that
process of human creation as long as
everybody's getting credit now let me
leave you with an amazing funk track
called found a child by ball and Jack
which you have never heard except that
you have